uh leader we're now live on youtube
i'll do a roll call first of all if
that's okay just please
counselor connect a present
counselor herst present answer jackie
hook
president councillor keeling present
councillor jefferies present councillor
mcgregor
present councillor present
[Music]
yes i'm present
[Music]
um welcome to the executive of 11th of
february
on a cold day and
i hope you stay warm and well so let's
crack on with the agenda there are no
apologies for absence
and i understand councillor david cox
will be joining us
for item 12 which is the notice of
motion referred from the previous cancer
meeting
so item two then is the minutes and uh
may i take a
uh a proposal and second to approve uh
the minutes assigned um from the last
meeting so
caso taylor proposing and counseling
keeling second
uh can i take a show of hands all those
in favor
yeah i think that's uh clearly curry
thank you as an animus all right uh
item three may ask if anyone has any
declarations of interest
either new or current on their existing
register of interests
when any items on the agenda
okay no well uh thank you very much but
if uh during the course of discussion on
the item
uh something does come to mind do
declare it at the time
thank you uh item four there are no
public questions i understand
no public questions leader all right so
let's move to item five the executive
forward plan
and that's to note the forthcoming
decisions and this will be updated
shortly
we can tend to note that yeah okay thank
you very much
so recommendations to full council item
six
the final financial plan proposals
uh and we'll move to uh councillor
keeling shortly and then martin
flickcroft
the chief financial officer on this um
leader of the council offer my thanks to
the over to over you and scrutiny
committees for their consideration
of the budget this year at their
meetings and for their recommendations
made to
executive today and for our
consideration before
making a recommendation to council i
really do appreciate
all of the work done by our councillors
on that
and for the comments and feedback we've
had from
a number of tony parish councils as well
across the district
and so with that i moved to councillor
keenan thank you
thank you leader leader i propose that
these
proposals be considered together with
any
subsequent consultation comments for
approval
by the council as the budget as the
final budget for 2021
22 and the outline plan for the
subsequent years
22 23 and 23 24.
the proposed budget includes an
increasing council tax of five pound
to 2.85 to
180 pounds and 17 pence
continued funding for a climate change
officer and enhanced planning
enforcement
increased provision in the capital
program for climate change projects
the continuing reduction in new homes
bonus
other central funding reductions in
particular
provisional assumptions for business
rates for future years
and the reset of the baseline
reserves at 13 of the net revenue budget
of just under 2 million pounds increased
support for housing including
team bridge 100 100 whilst backing
business
and bringing people and organizations
together
for local neighborhood planning
infrastructure delivery plan investment
funded
by communities infrastructure levy and
external sources
where available
of grant funding for the southwest
regional monitoring program
towns and central investment in
infrastructure and employment
use of long-term borrowing where
appropriate
an assumption of a 1.5 percent pay deal
and we continue the rural aid funding
freeze during the covid 19 pandemic
the executive committee recommended to
council
to note the mid-year review of treasury
management
showman appendix eight
that been the formal part of the final
budget report
dear colleagues this is a budget to
promote social
and economic recovery while balancing
the books
can i first pay tribute to our staff who
have contributed
to the savings made especially our chief
financial officer martin flincroft
and his team on the 4th of february
we received the final settlement from
government and there are no material
changes between the provisional
settlement
i shared with you on the 5th of january
and the final settlement
for team bridge district council
colleagues i would like to bring to your
attention
the new homes bonus report
of a new round of allocations were
announced in the settlement
year 11. these allocations are a one-off
and will not attract future legacy
payments
in fact the written statement underlines
that this will be the final set of
allocations
under the current approach ministers are
keen to replace
new homes bonus and plan to consult
shortly
on the future
there are also no guarantees given about
local government funding reform
although we are expecting the reforms to
be implemented in
2223 but the government's written
statement
only commits to revisiting the
priorities
for financial reform in the time for the
next
spending review ministers will also be
taking into account
wider work on the future of the business
rates
the final budget proposals are to date
for
from the latest lockdown so no sick
significant changes
apart from a budget gap widening next
year to 1.2 million
so moving forward we expect next year
will be balanced by earmarked reserves
a budget gap of 1.2 million in 2223
and 2.6 million in 23.24
so over the three years we have a budget
gap of 3.8 million
our capital program is unchanged just
slightly rescheduling
dates we will also consider whether we
can reinstate
the 0.5 million revenue contribution
from the reserve to capital and we'll
keep this as an option
colleagues we now have the data back
from our survey on the budget
and we have resounding support for the
key areas of
jobs housing and environment
two-thirds of those responding agreed to
increase
council tax backing business and
improving town centers
71 agreed that we should invest in
infrastructure
81 agreed to our proposals
sorry i'll correct that sorry 61
agree to our proposals to support
housing and approximately two-thirds
agreed to our carbon management plan
in terms of looking at our future
budgets we also had the following
responses
seventy percent of those responding
agreed to identify generating more
income
to reinvest in our council services
and 45 percent of the respondents want
to look at making more savings
leader colleagues this administration
through challenging times
has produced a budget for the residents
of teambridge
bringing forward our three main
priorities
jobs 2 million for empty employment
sites
investment in newton abbot high street
creating local jobs
housing team bridge first 100 council
homes
being built now and creating jobs for
the local
environment our commitment to the
climate emergency employing a climate
change officer
and our green leaf capital investments
working together across all political
groups
this budget will promote social and
economic recovery
while balancing the books
i'd like to pass you over to marty now
who will take you through the detail
and we will both be happy to answer any
questions at the end
martin please you very much
so um as indicated this is the final
budget proposals for the year 2122
and the outline figures for 23 20 up to
23 24.
um the figures in the report were based
on the provisional settlement and as
you've heard
the final supplement hasn't changed any
of those numbers there's nothing else to
report in that respect
and the final settlement also confirmed
the referendum limits being
the same at the higher of two percent or
above five pounds
the figures from the initial budget
proposals have been updated to reflect
the latest lockdown
um and there are no material changes to
the capital programme
the final budget proposals also include
that mid-year review of treasury
management to be noted by council
and some extra detail in the appendices
around cost per service area
so the key recommendations are that five
pound increase in cash tax to 180 pounds
and 17 pence
increasing climate change funding
continuing funding for enhanced planning
enforcement
maintaining revenue reserves at just
under 2 million pounds
increasing support for housing with the
team reach 100
infrastructure delivery plan investment
continuation of the grant funded
southwest regional coastal monitoring
programme
and town centre investment in
infrastructure and employment
section two of the executive report sets
the scene around reductions in
government funding
savings covered 19 impacts and the
inclusion of the team which 100 in the
capital programme
together provisions for climate change
projects and the future high street
funds bid
section 3 of the report provides more
details on the savings made to assist
with the budget gaps are rising
and i would refer you to 3.3 in
particular and
future costs impacting on the council in
3.9
and the mid-year review of treasury
management in 3.11
section four covers the revenue budget
at appendix four
and fees and charges appendix five there
are general inflationary increases in
most charges
and some charges at the net market have
been frozen after having been reduced
last year
and 4.2 to 4.4 gives more details around
those fees and charges
section 4 also looks at our proposed
change in council tax
and provides a multi-year summary of how
our funding has changed from government
including revenue support grant business
rates and new homes bonus
and the table there shows us 35
reduction over that time period
the key paragraph is 4.27 and how we
have funded the budget gaps
we still have a budget gap of 1.2
million in 2223
and 2.6 million in 23.24
on top of that the aspirations to put
another half a million pounds back into
our capital program through the revenue
funding
and would increase the savings further
and failure to deliver savings or obtain
greater funding from government
could trigger the issue of a section 114
notice in the future
section 5 includes details of the
capital programme
as mentioned no material changes from
the initial budget proposals that's at
appendix 7
and includes the housing by the team
bridge 100
climate change infrastructure and
employment
and section 6 covers the consultation on
the budget proposals
and the outcomes of a budget survey
which casual healing has
outlined earlier in our presentation
and they will form part of a full
council budget report appendix
um when the full council papers come out
later so that's a quick review of the
final budget report and happy to take
any questions thank you
thank you martin and thank you richard
i'm going to come to cancer person in a
moment
martin just during your presentation you
used a phrase the section 114 notice
which i'm
you know i'm sure we all know what is
but as we're in a public meeting
could you just briefly describe what a
section 114 notice is what what does
that mean
if it had to be if you had to exercise
that function
what did it mean for the council yeah so
as a chief finance officer um one of the
statutory duties
is to ensure that we have a balanced
budget every year
and we've managed to obtain that for 21
22 by
our use of earmarked reserves but that's
a one-off
use and going into the future years and
and looking at
our medium-term financial plan for those
future years it's clear at the moment
that there are budget gaps
so we have to try and work through how
we can meet those gaps higher
by making savings increase increasing
income or getting
more government support and we're
working all of those strands
if it becomes clear at some point in the
future that
we just cannot meet that balanced budget
that's where the chief finance officer
would need to raise
the section 114 notice which would give
a notice to members that it's pretty
clear in his or her view that
we just cannot balance the budget going
forward and we would have to
take uh key measures to um
stop expenditure um maybe stop services
for a period of time
to allow us to get into that balanced
position
so if i can summarize marching thank you
for that in essence
we're talking about we're balancing the
budget this year and next year but we've
very clearly identified from you and
council keeling that we've got to save
3.8 million over the next three years
and the
issue of a section 114 notice is that if
we fail to do that
your job as a chief financial officer is
to issue that notice
or to warn that it might be issued and
effectively the council has to strip
down to
just the essential expenditure to
maintain life and death services
that's correct yes lovely thank you for
that i'm going to move on martin but i
really appreciate
you know the clarity because i think
it's important that we know what that
means
uh counselor person thank you leader and
thank you martin and richard for those
those presentations it's just a very
minor sort of slightly picky point but
on the first
proposed budget recommendation
it ends with um 280 pounds 17
should that not then be caveated for a
band d
property because it obviously if you're
in a band a property that's currently
paying
i don't know 125 pounds
there's an implication that could go to
180 which clearly it's not
um so sort of for absolute clarity
should
as i say should that be carry out it
with a band-aid after it
yeah i can understand it's a phrase
that's sort of widely used because it's
always
reflecting of a band d um so
um yes you could add the words to to
bandy um when you come to the full
cancer proposals you'll see
the full range of um bands in there
where the 180 pounds and 17 pence is
reflected in bandy and you can see the
different bandings
for each particular band from a to h
thank you councillor mcgregor
thank you chair um martin it was just
just a quick one
is it fair to say that we knew that
there was going to be a gap
in the finances of the council prior to
maine 2019
and that this has been exacerbated
in some respects by the covid crisis
that we're we're all currently suffering
and in terms of income uh would it also
perhaps be fair to say that it might
cause some unnecessary pain in future
where we may have to go
beyond the minimum um sorry the maximum
uh and reference referendum amount
in future in terms of generating income
to try and cover the gap
so that we can maintain services as they
are at the moment
so in terms of um looking back
when we were looking forward for budget
gaps
i think we've been aware for a number of
years now that there was going to be
a budget gap um because we knew that the
business rates
system was going to be reset we thought
it would be reset
this year and we were aware that we were
likely to lose
most of the growth that we've obtained
through business rates over the past
five to six years and in that respect
that's why we've been putting money into
earmark reserves to reflect that cliff
edge
obviously that we didn't anticipate the
the pandemic and that's caused
even greater problems um but what the
pandemic did do was push back
the business rates um reset by a year
while government tried to gather their
thoughts
as to how they were going to fund us in
the future
um so the earmark reserves we put we set
aside for
that reset has now aided the
the pandemic difference where the
government hasn't met all of our
our income stream losses and so we've
been able to bridge the gap that way
um but that obviously meets part of the
problem and we can see the problem
arising in in two years time where we we
need to
address it so i'm hopeful that
a we can take actions ourselves to
address
the balance combined with working with
government which we have been doing over
the last 12 months
with more consultation this year around
how
we address those funding differences and
making the correct representations
and there's something come out recently
just on new homes bonus where there's a
consultation
for us to to look at which the deadline
things in april
um so i'll be looking at that shortly to
see and that allows
us to put our thoughts forward around
what we think should happen with new
homes bonus not just what one of the
streams that we need to look at
um but there's still no clarity about
from government as to when they will do
that that could happen next year
or they may with that with a pandemic
still you know
we're right in the middle of it they may
delay another year we just don't know
um i don't think government got the
answers at the moment um but we have to
assume it's going to happen
next year and so okay again council tax
i guess would be looked at
we have suggested that um councils
should have more independence around
setting their own levels um rather than
being a blanket
um figure for everyone um obviously
police have had a different figure to a
district council three times what we've
been allowed to set so
um there's some disparity there so i i
think working with government
um will allow us to see whether we can
uh change that going forward
um and that might be to the better of
team bridge
thank you for that martin um i think
it's been a
hugely challenging budget uh
and uh like i said i do repeat my uh
thanks to every scrutiny for their work
and
uh the work of 10 and parish councils
many of which have
stepped in to take on services or to do
more in their own area
um my view is that um
we're caught between a rock and a hard
place because so much of local
government finance is constrained by
government regulation
so although we have a choice about
whether we increase the council tax and
change by the maximum
five pounds permitted in effect the
government has assumed that we will have
included that
in our spending power so to do less
it will actually cause the government to
say well you obviously don't need the
money
and that may have an impact on our
ability to claim for
loss of business um that then feeds on
because over a good number of years
government generally has encouraged
councils to
rely less on government grants so we
don't get a re-support grant now and i
think we've heard previously
um in meetings that we've you know
that's gone down for something like four
million a year to nothing
and the impact of that is we need to uh
we've been encouraged to
raise money through fees and charges
through rental incomes
uh to invest which we've done and of
course the pandemic has not just
affected us
through loss of car parking leisure and
other other
other income sources it's affected many
other councils as well
and that's part of a dilemma we face and
i think all of us as councillors
also recognize that while we are talking
as a five pounds as a
you know bandy average as
martin flickcroft has said the police
will be charging 15 pounds so that's 20
plus whatever the town of crash councils
charge plus whatever the
fire said was charged plus demon candy
cancer which is the largest preceptor
so one one might talk of say two percent
for them
plus the three percent adult social care
that'll be five percent for devon county
council
um you know households may well be
expecting an average
council tax rise issue perhaps around
100 plans
the difficulty is for a lot of people of
course as we all know uh
they are hurting because of their jobs
because of the economy because they've
been furloughed
so it's no sense of joy that council tax
has to increase it's an awful tax
uh what i would say for those people who
live in chambers of course is that this
is the one council in devon
which continues to offer the 100 council
tax reduction for those in greatest need
and that's a very real benefit uh and we
are seeing that need coming in as more
people
come into universal credits more people
are claiming free school meals
as more people are looking for help from
the exceptional hardship fund
so i don't think colleagues we as a
council have any choice but to increase
the council tax for us by
um five pounds a year which is just less
than ten pence a week
but we do it mindful of all of the other
impacts that
people will be facing in our area and
that's why i think our budget is so
right to focus on the chambers 100
the modern council house program we've
got about creating jobs and investing in
the economy as and where we can
we're a part player in that there's a
big role for others as well including
the local enterprise partnership
and of course that work we're doing in
terms of climate change and that isn't
just about climate but that too
is an investment in jobs in helping
people
in cutting our carbon output so it has
many benefits so i think it's a very
active
budget i know councillor keeling has
proposed it i'm very happy to second it
i can't see any other questions
so may i ask colleagues if we can take a
vote
um and if it's unanimous so all those in
favor please
and uh sarah has it's a budget so do we
need to do a roll call on it as it's a
problem
we don't um just like not executive no
okay fine thank you so that's unanimous
and thank you very much for that
colleagues
so let's move on to the next item then
which is item seven
uh the tim public spaces protection
order
uh pages sixty three to eighty eight and
uh that's councillor wrigley
uh thank you leader yes so
we're bringing forward today for
executive to approve to go to full
council
a proposal for a public space protection
order around the center of
tin mouth principally focused around the
den the seafront
the back beach the triangle wellington
street and lower brook street
this is about trying to clamp down on
antisocial behavior
and poor behavior whilst people are
misusing abusing alcohol and other
substances
i'm always very low to look at public
space protection orders because they can
be quite
a draconian instrument but this one has
come forward at the request
of the local tin with police and has
been universally unanimously indeed
uh um approved by tinmoth town council
there have been problems in the centre
of tinmouth and this is an extra tool
that will help the local of the local
police
try to clamp down on those problems and
help
to solve them we continue
in our efforts to have less draconian
interventions to help the people
in that situation before it gets to this
point
but in terms of having an extra tool
this is considered necessary
and so i ask you to approve to uh send
this forward to full council please
uh thank you um
any comments from members of the um
executive council mcgregor
thank you jeff um in terms of the
public space protection i think um when
when you look at the outcry that was
was um occurring over the summer last
year
with quite a considerable amount of
anti-social behavior particularly around
the back beach
and and nearby streets and the promenade
i i think um
perhaps it will be slightly more
acceptable to to the residents of
timoth on that basis um one thing i was
going to ask is if we could
put an amendment into uh recommendation
2b
where it says in consultation with the
solicitor of the council makes such
minor amendments to the draft order she
considered appropriate
before the order is sealed um that
members of the executive are notified of
those changes as well
uh thank you council mcgregor yes uh we
usually do have
in these um in these the these delegated
powers there
that it's done in consultation with the
executive member concerned um
and if you would like to uh put to that
then i would be happy to
happy to uh uh take that amendment
uh well i think if colleagues are happy
we'll just include
um i think that's sensible consultation
um
okay anyone content with that okay
anything else anyone needs to say
uh counselor cox i just have to say to
you you haven't previously asked to
speak on this item so i'm not allowing
you to do it now
you have to ask to speak in advance of
the meeting but you are entitled to
speak on the motion
item 12. thank you um
any other comments right so can we take
a
show of hands in favor of item uh seven
leader could we just have a proposal in
a second though because i haven't had
that
i just want to clarify it's in
consultation
uh with the solicitor to the council did
you want to
and and is it the executive member
or the that all executive are notified
the executive member for communities uh
currently in
yeah yeah yeah so that's sorry i just
clarify
that's being added to the
recommendations
that's right so it's the the solicitor
and the executive member for homes and
communities i just want to
be sure martin's nodding at me so yes
that's fine so if i could have a
proposal and a second for that
well councillor wrigley will propose and
council mcgregor is second
okay thank you and all those in favor
thank you very much for that okay okay
so let's move to item eight which is the
notice of motion equality of
representation
uh and counselor jefferies
hello can you hear me i'm still having
trouble with my internet
we can hear you very well okay thank you
um so colleagues this paper is a
culmination
of a large amount of input from members
and across departments regarding the
continuing support and recognition of
diverse communities
requirements and contributions to team
bridge and the uk
the work that has been done to bring
these recommendations to you today
has informed the development of similar
within devon county and will contin
continue to contribute to the wider
governmental review
it reflects everyone's continuing
commitment to change within this area
i want to thank those of you who have
made the effort to contact me to seek
greater understanding
of what you can do or are doing
personally and to put forward your views
in particular members of audit scrutiny
the working groups and officers
i hope that this paper actually
accurately reflects those discussions
2020 particularly saw
appealing back of understanding of what
those of us in diverse communities face
in the uk and internationally and with a
desire for change and even greater
resolve to come together
within all communities to achieve that
change
so this paper's recommendations to go to
full council
um are that that have come out of the
audit scrutiny committee
and their motions one through seven from
the bain
notice of motion and this includes
briefly
um in qualities training for members and
this is
isn't exhaustive because it's all in the
text
a review of the equality's policy
detailed in section 2.2
for the leader to write to the secretary
of state in respect of educational
representation
for bain communities both currently and
historically
and also calling for a national debate
led by the baim community
we have seen a revision of the
councillors community fund form
which is detailed in section 2.3 and
that refers specifically to the
investigation into street naming
which which i feel has been
rigorously discussed and this section
provides the detail of this
motion number three highlights the
education project which has secured
funding
um it's been put back slightly this year
due to the restrictions that have been
in place but we are going into the
school
to provide um the project in september
2021 starting with timmoth community
school
so colleagues i'm excited to be able to
present this paper to you today and hope
that you will accept the recommendations
to take
to full council laid out in full to
ensure team bridge continues to
demonstrate best practice
in the field of addressing support for
rural diversity and the pain
experience thank you
thank you very much uh coaster jeffries
appreciate that any comments from our
colleagues
in that case i'd like to thank everyone
because i know it's gone through
a number of committees in the council
have been scrutinized scrutiny
um and from the original motion i think
it's taken
um its time quite rightly to be thought
through and i'm very happy to see this
going to council
so nina i guess you are proposing
um i'm very happy to second uh
can we take a show of hands a favor
thank you very much and thank you to
everyone for all of their work on that
uh and i know officers have been
involved soon it's very good piece of
work
thank you um so can i move into item
uh nine which is the proposed long
lettings
and field transfer of the uh wc's uh and
i think that was because the two list
no i think that it is is counseling
yeah yet you just gave me a minor heart
attack there thank you
uh rick richard guide us to the public
thank
thank you leader um i i suppose i'll be
known for the toilets and the budget
and this uh executive meeting um leader
as you mentioned earlier you know we've
been in discussions with some of the
towns and parishes
about how they can help us and we can
help them
with assets and making long-term savings
so this is a proposal for a long
letting and a freehold transfer of
public wc's
to timothy town council we have a
proposal before us
and i'll read the detail on that so it's
clear to everyone
it is proposed that team bridge grants
the following legal interest to the town
council to ensure
that the facilities remain open and
operational
for the longer term in respect of the
existing
women's and men's public wc buildings at
jubilee shelter
east cliff promenade
it is proposed that the town council be
granted full repairing
and ensuring leasehold interest for a
term of 60 years
in respect to the new public wc's
sites at eastcliff car park timmouth
to replace the wc that have already been
demolished
and quayside car park timmouth
as an alternative to the closed wc at
brunswick street
it is proposed that the town council
again be granted full repairing
and ensuring leasehold interest for the
term of 60 years
in the respect of the premise at the den
timoth
it is proposed that the town council be
granted a full repairing
and ensuring leasehold interest for a
term of 60 years
but subject to the potential provision
of wc
facilities elsewhere at the den in the
event that the current facilities are
replaced
for back of house facility to support
the letting
of the beachcomber building as a
destination cafe restaurant
in this regard discussions are ongoing
with the town council in respect of the
suitable alternative site for the town
council to construct
new facilities in respect to the
premises at lower brook street
timoth it is proposed that bridge pass
on
its interest to the town council by way
of a transfer
of a free old interest subject to
restrictive
covenants and overage
colleagues i ask that the executive
to approve the course of action set out
in the proposal
of this report this will
this approval will benefit both
residents and visitors to timothy
long term thank you sure
richard i'm taking your proposing um do
we have a second
okay thank you council mcgregor was
second uh anyone wish to speak on this
item
no okay that was good i mean it does
look good i'm grateful for tim with town
council
um for you know the work that they're
doing and taking control
there and i think it's a very good deal
from team bridge too
so it's a good example of a way um the
district and
tana parish councils can work together
so it's uh good to see this report
coming to
coming to us and we're on the
recommendation to council
um so all those in favor
yeah lovely thank you very much none of
us isn't it thank you
so we moved to item 10 which is the
public spaces protection order
controller dogs
review group report and they're going to
move to cancer chewhurst
um who shouldn't be surprised at this
one and also
to councillor nutley who shared the
review thank you
uh alice there thank you very much
leader um
but before i start uh councillor purser
mentioned that uh he'd seen in the
in the media that uh that been uh a fire
in in a refuse truck and i've had
confirmation that it was in fact one of
our refuge trucks
uh no one was imid it was uh injured
um it was only a minor electrical fire
and it's actually caused very little
damage to to the truck
concerned so um just to reassure
everybody
um that we are still on track and and
and
collecting everybody's refuse as per
normal
so good morning colleagues um the the
public spaces uh protection order for
responsible
dog ownership came into force on the 1st
of april
2019 the pspo provided
consistent dog controls for all public
spaces in team bridge
there are a number of controls including
dog fouling
dogs on leads and controlling access to
beaches
a review group was set up and have
reported
once already to members but agreed to
review the controls
after one year meetings were held last
year
and the report of the review group went
to overview and scrutiny
our committee number one uh on the
22nd of december last year uh
i'd like to ask councillor nutley who
was the chair of the review group
to present the two recommendations that
are being brought forward
here uh today to the executive for
approval
however as the executive member for this
area of work i fully
support the controls that the pspo gives
officers i also agree with the first
recommendation that the review group
along with officers review the controls
and bring back to executive
recommendations on re renewing
the pspo we need to focus
our publicity to educate the public
but i'm keen that our officers are able
to focus on taking
robust enforcement action where
necessary
the use of signs is a helpful tool where
town and parish councils can support the
work of our officers
we will support them with a tool kit of
posters and literature for them to use
in their local area if they require
support with funding
they could approach their local ward
members
i therefore propose the following
amendment to the second recommendation
and i believe that this has been forward
uh forwarded around
two colleagues and that amendment reads
a boards or similar for dog fouling hot
spot areas
being financed through town and parish
councils and district councillors
community fund scheme where required
town and parish councils can advise
so that a board can be located when
and where necessary other preventative
methods of display
such as pavement stenciling and lamppost
signs
will also be explored as part of this
initiative the environment protection
manager
and councillors decox and phipps have
discussions with tinmouth town council
to support them in a publicity campaign
and for them to arrange for appropriate
signage
for the den in order to address concerns
raised
in relation to that area so
that that's my bit leader um thank you
and before we move to uh council natalie
can we just have a second day for that
amendment please and the recommendation
somebody council mcgregor
super uh councillor nutley john you
chaired the review group
yeah thank you leader and members um
before i move on to that if i may
i was obviously very interested in the
tinvest report on there
and under the prohibitions and
requirements i was quite interested in
6a maybe it can be explained at some
stage
not not this morning but it started off
by saying
not to shall shout so i'm not quite
understand what that actually meant but
maybe it can be explained later
i see uh cancer wrigley's got his hand
up
that is a typographical error that will
be corrected before it goes to full
council
okay
um yeah moving on if i may thank you
leader um well firstly obviously this
has been
a very interesting uh piece of work that
we've done but
firstly i would like to thank our
environmental officer david eaton
for all the work and input that he has
done and also trish
corns for all the documentation she has
had to record
since we started the review group and to
my fellow committee members
for their support over the years um
we carried out the consultation um
survey at the beginning of
2019 having had 151
um feedbacks which i've got here quite a
bit
all of which having various views on the
proposals being put forward
and which i found some very interesting
comments
and i have to say i actually read every
one of them and highlighted various
points on them
um we then invited some of the people to
take part in the survey to come along to
meetings
to allow them to give further comments
and allow us to express
the council's intentions um
on our and actions that we we were
taking
some of which were the number of dogs
that some people can handle
and control at any one time to stamp out
the
pot and possible fine those that are
allowing their dogs to foul
and not pick up afterwards we also
implemented the
time of year restrictions that would be
placed on beaches
um closing and and obviously reopening
we looked at the way some dog businesses
were operating some of which had
licenses granted by tdc
to run their business from home it was
thought the dog
license could be introduced locally but
as there is no government legislation
it would be difficult to implement we
have looked at ways to encourage those
that
do not pick up after their dogs and one
of which has been
obviously recommended was
a boards but obviously maybe polite
notice it put on them
um but i think that's uh covers i think
most of the
what we've we've been carrying out and
obviously
you've all seen the uh report and i
i must say i agree with the uh
the um amended recommendation that's
been put forward
but we'll ask members um for your views
and comments
thank you very much councillor and also
for the work that you've done on the
review group it's
very much appreciated uh counselor hook
thank you um i just wanted to um suggest
another
um slight addition to the amendment um
that
uh councillor juha suggested um
recognizing that
there are sort of two main um
concerns i believe one one of them is
dog fouling
and the other one is um dogs off leads
so one of the bylaws was that dogs
should be on leads on the highway
adjacent to the highway
and on shared use cycle paths
and so when we're talking about these a
boards and publicity
um at the moment it only talks about
dogs island so can we also add in
that it should be um it also include
areas where there is a problem with dogs
being on
leads because i feel that possibly not
everybody knows so it's not well
publicized we haven't publicized this
particular bylaw
particularly comprehensively and perhaps
we ought to because
maybe it is the case that lots of people
do not know that they should be doing
that
can we take some guidance uh alice then
maybe might need to
ask the officer because i'm not sure
that yeah okay alistair
so i'm i'm not sure if we have
uh david eaton with us we do
um so we fantastic um as i understand it
uh that the two are sort of essentially
um what one and the same in the areas
where
dogs are off leads tends to be areas
where there are particular problems with
dog fowling but i'll i'll let david um
say his species can i say jackie would
you mind just taking down your hand
thank you david eaton thank you
um so the the controls within the pspo
there are
um eight specific controls the review
group when they met
the focus was around dog fouling but i
can see no reason
for us not to use the a boards for
different hot spots for different areas
and potentially we would use consider
using that in the future
for littering and fly tipping as well so
i think the focus of the review group
was on dog fouling
which is why the recommendation is as
before you but the controls also cover
um the areas that councillor hook um has
mentioned
so can i just check with clarity council
hooks proposed amendment
does it add anything or is it
effectively included in what we've got
now
um if you add
um dogs on leads um as per the control
you potentially are excluding the other
controls within the pspo
my proposal um i don't think i'm allowed
to propose but my suggestion
is that the the um the able to cover the
controls
of the pspo and we we choose the
appropriate wording depending on the
appropriate location
yes i think that's comprehensive isn't
it
martin councillor wrigley uh thank you
leader
um yes i was just going to support uh
councillor hook
one of the big things that uh was
encouraging within dawlish particularly
for this pspo
uh was after we had a black swan taken
out by a dog that was off a lead so
having the dogs on leads
is an important thing so fully support
the
proposal to change it into all of the
all of the controls as as suggested
uh uh rather than just the dog fouling
so for clarity i think what david eaton
is just saying to us is that
actually what this does does allow us to
do all of those things
but if you put in one it might suggest
the others don't apply
i think that's where we're at um
so what i'm going to suggest is that two
which was amended by councillor juhist
is the one that we should approve
and what we've heard from david eaton is
that would allow the council
to use it the process flexibly
to support the right regulation in the
right place
okay have i got that right
david you're nodding let's go dallas
thank you that's good
excellent all right um martin your
hand's still up sorry
did you need to say something more
absolutely lovely so um
aleister you're proposing may i take a
second
um i think we had well we'll take
margaret wrigley
uh all those in favor
okay lovely thank you very much and
thank you david
eaton uh environmental production
manager for that too
let's move on to the next item which is
eleven the devon
joint waste strategy public consultation
uh and this is uh cancer dues as well
thank you very much uh leader yes um i
would like to recommend to executive
that the content of the draft resource
and waste management strategy
for devon and torbay is approved for
public consultation
uh clearly it's important we get that
that sort of message
out there it's an important strategy
and takes us through to 2030.
all right um so you're proposing may
have a second for that please uh
councillor taylor and all those in
favour
unanimous lovely thank you very much for
that
so we move to the final item which is
the
notice of motion referred from the last
council meeting regarding the
retention of the trench japan's
universal credit uplift
uh the motion was submitted by
councillor david cox
and david you're with us so please speak
to the motion
uh thank you mr uh thank you leader um
the
i i hope uh i will get unanimous support
for this
the indications from government are that
this is uh likely
that they are likely to be able to
support this and i think
the uh this council's um support for
the uplift will help concentrate minds
at government level
it's one of the one things that can do
to help people who are
suffering because of the covid emergency
and it's a good way to deal with poverty
uh this district council is doing its
bit as the leader has mentioned with the
council tax discount of 100
the only council i think in devon in
fact i think the only council in the
south west i might be wrong
that does this so i hope we will support
this motion
as i say we're not just asking
government to do this we're doing things
ourselves
and i know i would congratulate officers
at teamwork district council who've got
the
grants out really quickly and helped
businesses and
individuals with the hardship fund so i
hope people will support this
20 pound uplift to
universal credit and to the legacy
benefits thank you
thank you dave it may ask just just to
clarify when we talk about the tragedy
if that's 20 pounds a week isn't it it
is 20 pounds a week to universal credit
we're also asking that legacy benefits
we weren't included in that uplift
are included so people who are on the
olds
but benefits schemes aren't benefiting
from that um
so it would be helpful if they if the
legacy benefits got it as well
but when we talk about the change of
banks we don't often say what the time
span is and some people might think
20 pounds a and that's real spending
power in our local economy
absolutely it means money it means we
the evidence is that people who are on
lower incomes tend to spend their money
locally in the local economy
so it will boost our small businesses
and we'll boost our local economy so it
is money into team bridge
okay thank you i've got a couple of
speakers i had andrew mcgregor first i
think
um i put my hand down because uh my
point has just been covered both by
yourself and camera
thank you cancer jefferies
thanks i just wanted to um fully support
this i i personally feel
given that there's rising costs that
seem to be ongoing that the 20 pounds a
week really isn't enough
for people and with what they're facing
which is why we're seeing so many
people um weekly increasingly going to
um need help
with their food costs and things like
that so um yes
it would be good to turn government's
eye to this and
get them to understand what people are
facing in our communities
thank you good thank you very much uh
nina
uh so taking nina your proposal
recommendation to
council to approve it uh martin your
second cancer rigor was second
all those in favor
that's unanimous lovely uh thank you
very much
thank you colleagues thank you uh david
that concludes our business for the
executives this morning i thank you for
your time
now and for going through that and for
the work that you've done in preparing
reports that have brought
us to today's meeting and also to our
officers for their support as well
so thank you very much and from today's
meeting we will clearly have a busy
council meeting
uh next week when we set the budget uh
and
look at a variety of other issues so
thank you very much have a lovely day
bye-bye bye now